does it really say don't be ugly uh it
should say it right after that no it
doesn't say that the word of let down I
wonder what the Chinese character for
ugly is so
does it look funny
I mean all the Chinese
[Laughter]
[Music]
so uh you guys are fans of Stephen Chow
I love Stephen Chow big fan Colleen
hates him you hate him
um I don't know who this is
why don't you explain to Steven Jones
yeah who is this give me a reference we
played soccer in one movie he's one of
the greatest directors God damn that was
gonna be bad writer director Kung Fu
Hustle
hustle and and Shaolin Soccer I was
gonna get there just let me take some
time now gather my thoughts he's got
that he's got that hit movie Shaolin
Soccer that's the one I think most
people have seen and also Kung Fu Hustle
challenge soccer came out 22 years ago
wow it's still it's so it still holds up
it's one of my favorite movies ever it
looks good what was the other one there
was kung fu no kung fu is the most
recent I mean he's got it you said you
have a favorite one well challenge
soccer and there's another one my ACT my
absolute favorite Stephen Child movie is
king of comedy oh which is right which
is a deep deep cut there's tons of them
there's like he has like over 10 movies
yeah
he has a good Chinese Odyssey as well
which I know there's like he has uh his
own parody of like a god of gamblers one
too oh tight and he has fight back to
school which is like his spy one
yeah he's a lot of a lot of crap but um
speaking of Shaolin Soccer though 22
years later he's now
um announcing a sequel what what do you
think the sequel's about pickleball dude
because everyone's talking about
pickleball pickleball's hot right now
pickleball it's hot is it hot it's hot
it's hotter than hell let's pick again
it's a sport that everyone it's
apparently it's the fastest growing
sport in America what is it though
it's tennis it's like tennis but with a
different rack do you like it tennis and
Batman right yeah no the sequel is still
soccer related oh okay what's the
difference why would it it can't it's
challenging it's Shaolin Soccer too with
a Twist
they're all black
that's good that'd be cool that's a good
twist yeah yeah they're all they're all
Eddie Murphy in different costumes Eddie
Murphy player Chinese guy
I'd watch that I think he's done that
because it could be like Hong Kong you
know how Hong Kong is hella
Multicultural right it could be like
about the African Community in Hong Kong
which oh dude it was crazy like one day
I was going down this Chinese ass alley
in Hong Kong and they're trying to sell
me some [__] yeah and slowly it turned
into little Africa Market wow and then
me and my buddy were walking around like
what the [__] and you know how like Hong
Kong has all those weird little
Alleyways so it's like you go through
and then before you know it it's like
incense
fabric just you feel like you're in the
middle of like a completely different
country yeah so imagine those guys
growing up in Hong Kong but then soccer
that'd be interesting I hate to let you
down it's not that yeah
that's a better movie it's arguably you
know what that would be the better movie
but it's actually uh gonna be
Shaolin women's soccer oh [__] off
cool play in the park
huh yeah
even ciao was like that what do you mean
like what what is a guy like Disney
trying to be all walking [__] I don't
know if he's trying to be woke I think
but here's the thing that I think is and
again like I'm predicting here but
Shaolin women's soccer to me doesn't
sound right because Shaolin Soccer
itself the woman saved the day yeah the
ugly girl
yeah
yeah no but she's literally the ugly
girl remember like they they all they
[__] zoomed in on her ugly ass face
they made she's hot by that yeah she
takes her glasses off and they're like
that's good it's a happy ending then but
the thing is she Saves the Day in the
first one yeah so it feels redundant
maybe he saw Ocean's eight and was like
I could do that he saw Ghostbusters and
was like I love the tank yeah he sold
the box office he's like wow he's like
he's like and you know what women's
soccer gets low ratings too good not so
so one of the main uh characteristics
about why this is uh getting attention
isn't just that he announced channel in
soccer he had a weird announcement
that's kind of like what is he saying
here so he uh I feel like there's got to
be a Twist yeah there has to be because
he's such a smart dude I feel like
there's got to be like something I don't
know but he's also did you guys know
that like I've always like idolized them
and then once you really like look into
how people see him he gets into a lot of
bad [__] like people a lot of people
don't like him really like what kind of
bad [__] are you talking about it's just
kind of a dick hole like right A lot of
people don't want to work with like all
directors yeah yeah yeah like most
directors kind of a tyrant but I don't
know any director that has like this oh
this guy's [__] amazing like the
Keanu Reeves like Vibe like everyone
says Keanu Reeves everyone loves that
guy I know someone that worked with him
recently and I heard like really don't
say that oh nothing like like super
negative but a sense of like this guy
sniffs his own farts for sure oh I've
heard that about nothing crazy but just
at the point of like oh he won't like
talk to you onset that type of [__] but
I don't know maybe that's standard
it was me
so
um he announced a casting call for
pretty girls instructing hotties to
email their picks and he warned against
photoshopping them okay now I like this
guy that's funny that's that's pretty
good it's good to use your power to try
to get with women yeah yeah it's really
weird I can always so he's just doing a
straight Casting Couch to North like
just the regular public because here's
the so he posted this thing on Instagram
right and there's the
um I guess the Cantonese uh caption but
then there's an English one under it so
I don't know if it's a hard sounds like
a mistranslation but he goes here's my
birthday wish to spend the good time
with so many pretty girls young
beautiful smart curvy athletic all
countries are welcome the more the
better let's people mounted people see
just don't be ugly
those terms I'd be like I want to be
extra careful because when you say
athletic there are some people who think
like cake eating is a [__] sport so I
would even I would just put like in
parentheses like take it easy
it's along the same tone just to be
clear yeah yeah I'm a competitive eater
Steve scale breaking
but the funny thing is all the women and
competitive eating are skinny that is
true that is a good point that is a good
point even the top guys are skinny oh
dude our boy the hot dog eater is
skinniest [__] yeah he's skinny
smart [__] you see that chick on on
Instagram or uh social media her name is
like she's Asian chick her name is uh
Raina or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
and she bro she's like she's very petite
but she'll take down like a 10 pound
burger yeah and like very systematically
just tear it apart and you're like what
the [__] I actually connected with her
about coming on to Jacob really yeah she
said she's down is she gonna eat for us
yeah because Andy ate the um Andy Asian
dude he uh suggested her to us and then
she like he put us in like a group chat
together oh tight because we had a
friend of Furious Pete that came on and
then we took him to one of our favorite
burger places at that time Grill them
all in Alhambra and those burgers are
half pound Burgers they're legit and
then we're like
we know that like competitive eaters
like it's just like comedians are like
say hey go tell me a joke like they hate
like hey eat something in front of me
yeah but it's really I didn't know that
eat something quickly
how about this Bola oatmeal go hey why
aren't you dunking with water you
[__] awesome you're [__] freaky
but also we're curious you know yeah so
we're like and these burgers are big and
then so he was down which is really cool
and he's like he's like I'll do one for
you guys and I'll eat one for fun for
myself like Hollywood I'll actually eat
it you know like one for flavor because
when you just gotta figure it out you
don't get to enjoy it oh it's because
he's for Speed so the first one he ate
for us and it was two seconds and a
burger this big he just rips it and he
just smashes gone in two seconds yes he
uses his hands as a part of his chewing
too rips it and it's gone yeah and then
the second Burger he just ate like a
normal person and we're just talking we
vlogged it like a normal guy did you
guys ask him about like after like they
do giant challenges because that's what
I'm really curious about some people
throw it up right after some people puke
it just want to know what the bathroom's
like oh they just they just puke it yeah
some people do I like the idea of taking
a competitive eater out for lunch and he
goes oh man food
I'm gonna do this I don't wanna
I do this for work
just throwing a face I like the idea too
that they're not doing the competitive
eating thing and then later on you're
like that guy's [__] fake he's not
even really like that in real life
he's been slow yeah
he's a he's a [__] fake he takes
forever to eat his lunch
I pee I beat him I ate my lunch I had my
lunch before he did make an Instagram
post about it I wonder if there are fans
think that they're [__] they're like
oh competitive eaters they're just all
[__] they're so mean yeah yeah
they're so rude he didn't eat that
burger for me in front of him so yeah he
said at the Stephen Chow said at the
bottom of his caption uh Photoshop photo
will never work it will be condemned by
us and by the United Nations
which is like of course he's [__]
around yeah so he wants a birthday party
with just a bunch of hot girls only I
think so what does that have to wait is
he casting or
trying to get a birthday
girls no I don't think he's having a
birthday party I think I think his
birthday wish is that people submit
their material to be cast for this movie
I don't know or do you think it's like a
Lost in Translation thing it might be
like he wrote something like Chinese or
Cantonese maybe you should read it can
you read it maybe some words I'm not
back I have like a third grade reading
level
I mean okay today I only have one wish
Johnson and something eat up
I don't know what the [__] that says
good [__]
okay so young
young beautiful I think this is like
really nice body 10 something I think
this is like you need to be like
really smart
oh and then you need to have uh
uh the the elite the most Elite Physical
capability capable woman okay
Ichi I wonder what woman is
reading this going that's me and I think
uh together we will look at I'm [__]
smart together we'll look at the the
Rays of the sun uh oh yeah I think I
think it's writing very sarcastically in
Chinese so I think when you translate it
I think some of it yeah that actually
shines and he says um the number of
people we have is not enough
something something where oh so that's
why he's doing a casting call if you go
it goes I'll go from Ocean to Mountain
to find the right woman or something
does it really say don't be ugly uh
it should say it right after that no it
doesn't say that I don't think so the
word of let down I wish you said it I
wonder what the Chinese character for
ugly is so
does it look funny
I mean all the Chinese letters look
funny
the only the only people that like
Chinese character are NBA basketball
players
I don't know how to read a lot of these
things but yeah I think it's a um I
think you got most of it and it looks
like Chris cut fries to me man
oh yeah they did they did say like
mountain people see yeah they
mistranslated it because it says let's
people mountain people see
and what they're saying is like I think
like from the mountains to the Sea yeah
let's mountain people I'm curious
because he hasn't made a movie in a long
time in a long long time yeah so it'd be
cool to see oh but he did do a sequel to
king of comedy in like 2019 or something
like that but I didn't see it
because to me he's kind of like the
Taiko ytt before tiger whites equal
comedy equal heart dude he's so freaking
funny man yeah and he's always the
underdog in his movies dude what if the
girl the ugly girl in Shaolin Soccer she
creates like a female team because she's
like the coach now and that's the sequel
and then the guy saves the day in this
one yeah thank God finally and in Social
context what's cool about the uh the
ugly girl in Shaolin Soccer she was like
imagine
um what was it the Twilight series
Kristen Stewart Stewart so imagine when
Twilight was at its hottest yeah Kristen
Stewart was like the it girl and then in
the next comedy movie She's casted as
the ugly [__] so it was like it was
like uh in the in the that's really
that's a role so inshot so I think
people were excited to see her play that
that role yeah homely a homely [__] yeah
because they know what she actually is
in Hong Kong
yeah so it's like kind of like that's
the same thing he did with those girls
with the mustaches remember in this
channel in soccer there's these two
chicks that have mustaches but they're
always like hot leads in his movies yeah
like he likes to flip them and stuff
that's funny yeah
foreign
[Music]